this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 1000 people to use the link in
the description or receive two free
months of skill shares Premium
Membership
a young girl named Sarah got ready for
her first day of fifth grade she was at
a new school in a new town after having
moved over the summer naturally she was
scared and nervous about what it would
be like and if she would be liked before
leaving for school she sat at the
kitchen table enjoying her favorite
cartoon and eating her favorite cereal
about two hours later she was at school
lost and nervous as the first school day
turned into the first school week first
month and first half of the year
Sarah remained fairly nervous each day
every day felt like a minefield of
social games in classrooms dresses she
worried about boys and she worried about
the popular girls that weren't very
friendly to her she wasn't bullied per
se but she often felt inferior and
uncomfortable at about halfway through
the year though Sarah had found a nice
little friend group of other kids
dealing with the same things which
helped one of the few things that helped
her get through each week after morning
cartoons in serial was recessed with
their friends they wouldn't need to do
too much just hang out joke freely swing
on the swings and flirt with each other
the whole world became an elementary
school playground as everything else
dissolved outside the fence of the
schoolyard every Monday Sarah had a math
test after recess though which always
kind of ruined the day for her she
struggled with math and always felt
stupid during the tests every Wednesday
and Friday she also had to give
presentations into classes which he also
hated just in general she felt more
stressed that year than any previous
school year and every day was sort of an
uphill battle
one day after a math test Sarah left
class to go get a drink of water
on her way to the water fountain she
noticed a second or third grader crying
in the hallway with a guidance counselor
the counselor was saying it's okay it's
just a game it's just a game over and
over as Sarah walked past them she
thought to herself how little kids have
no idea how good they have it
six years later Sarah was 16 and a
junior in high school it had been one of
her hardest school years yet she
struggled to keep her grades up and felt
the pressure of needing to more than
ever for the first time she started
looking at colleges and having to think
about her life after school all of it
terrified and stressed her out
that same year Sarah got her license and
could essentially go wherever she wanted
she had to schedule around when her
older brother was using the family's
second car though which meant her and
her brother fought over it nearly every
time when she did get to use it though
Sarah and her friends would go out and
enjoy the new sense of freedom that came
with being that age they would go to the
park the mall parties each other's
houses and sometimes just drive around
and smoke weed and get food most of the
time it was really fun but a lot of the
times Sarah felt a weird increasing
amount of competitiveness with her
friends especially when boys were around
one boy in particular who Sarah liked a
lot ended up making out with one of her
friends while they were at the mall
together
of course this devastated Sarah and she
rushed off and sat in the food court by
herself trying not to cry while she
waited for her mom to come pick her up
so to avoid going home with her friends
while she sat there thinking about how
horrible the year had been with all the
stresses of school and new
responsibilities and increasing social
challenges a group of three little girls
who looked to be around fifth or sixth
grade walked by her and sat at a table
just a couple feet away
Sarah overheard them complaining about a
teacher or something and she
condescendingly laughed to herself she
thought about how they had no idea how
easy they had it simultaneously she was
suddenly reminded of her own elementary
in middle school years she remembered
how easy and fun it was to be at an age
when you still had things like recess
just hanging out flirting with boys with
no real pressure and no real life
stresses other than silly little tests
and other dumb little kids she got
visuals in her head of her 5th and 6th
grade classrooms and hallways and so on
recalling various specific memories that
she had forgotten about but we're now
suddenly being played out of the strange
storage center of the brain like blurry
little movies in that moment she felt a
longing to be back there
eight more years went by Sara was 24
living in New York City after going to
college in Syracuse New York several
hundred miles away from home she decided
to stay in New York after graduating and
moved to the city for work she was
living in an apartment that she split
with four other people it was tight
quarters but the group had sort of
become like a little family and
something was always going on in the
apartment the whole group would
sometimes go to the bars and clubs
together bringing their other friend
groups all into one big one however a
good percentage of the time most of her
friends and roommates were busy tired or
uninterested in going out all with their
own lives
relationships job schedules and so on
during this time despite living with
four people sara constantly felt lonely
it had been three years since she broke
up with the guy she dated seriously in
college she broke up with him because he
drank all the time and was an [ __ ]
when he did but she still wasn't really
over him and she definitely wasn't over
being alone for work during this time
Sarah was a typesetter for a midsize
publishing company helping create text
layouts for business oriented books and
print publications the job was both
tedious and stressful the pressure of
the work environment paired with her
lack of personal connection to the
outcome made it meaninglessly difficult
she loved living in New York City though
and her options were limited in order to
afford the nearly impossible cost to
stay in order to try and increase her
income
ever since graduating college she had
been trying to build up her own graphic
design business on the side which he put
most of her spare time towards she was
always looking for freelance projects
and working on personal portfolio pieces
but she had yet to find any sort of
success she worried deeply about the
direction of her life or lack thereof
and felt aimless incapable and afraid of
never finding success in anything
personally meaningful the unknown and
uncertainty not at her like a cramped
muscle in her spine one night on a
fairly ordinary Saturday Sara drank wine
by herself in her apartment while
working on a graphic design piece a
couple hours in she was properly drunk
while looking for source material and
old files she ended up looking through
old photos on her laptop
specifically photos of her and her
ex-boyfriend in college this then led
her to look at other old photos and
videos from college in high school
parties projects travels dorms her
winter and summer breaks videos that her
friends made at sleepovers and so on she
thought about how fun college was and
how easy high school was to have friends
that weren't always busy and to have fun
just driving around and going to the
mall to not have to worry about real
money problems to have summers that
still felt like summers to have
semesters that ended and began to just
be a student with nothing that's serious
on their plate and to still have a
boyfriend who made her loneliness feel
less real in this moment Sarah felt a
deep nostalgic longing to be back in the
time of the photos 21 years went by
sarah was 44 and had since become a wife
a successful independent graphic
designer
and a mother of two boys when she was 36
one of her designs that she posted on
the Internet got noticed by the founder
of a start-up tech company the founder
liked it so much she reached out and
asked Sarah if the company could
purchase an iteration of the design and
use it as their logo Sarah of course
agreed and two years later after the
company had become a massive success she
was given the opportunity to lead the
company's brand identity icon designs
and nearly all other visual elements
ever since Sarah slowly became a highly
sought after world-renowned graphic
designer eventually starting her own
studio and design consulting agency
partnering with several other industry
leaders between this and her two
children almost every week was filled to
maximum capacity there was never a dull
moment which was engaging but there was
never a dull moment which was also
absolutely exhausting she appreciated
her job and loved her family but Sarah
often found herself feeling suffocated
by her life not just by the intense
stress pressure or responsibility of
everything but by the feeling that all
possibilities for anything else were
essentially gone forever on one Friday
Sarah picked up her youngest son from
baseball practice in between two of her
afternoon meetings on the way back to
the office
Sarah stopped for a drink at a local bar
to give herself a moment to breathe she
had two more meetings that day and then
a seminar presentation that night along
with two more big presentations over the
weekend this was a lot but normal for
her while at the bar a small group of 20
or 30 something year olds came in and
sat
they were talking about what sounded
like a business they were working on or
towards Sarah listen while she drank she
looked over out of the corner of her
eyes and thought about how nice it would
be to be that age again to still have a
friend group like that to be able to go
out once or twice a weekend with no
worries or even just be able to stay in
by herself and drink wine relax and work
on her own projects with no distractions
so you remember the times when she was
first living in the city the shitty
apartments that she loved the roommates
that were always around to have fun the
nights out being young and single she
thought back to how exciting it was to
be in the face of the unknown everything
in her life now was mostly figured out
and now she longed to be back when
nothing was figured out and everything
was still possible she thought to
herself almost slightly mad at the naive
young adults next to her that 20 year
olds never realized how good they have
it the last 40 years went by
Sarah was 84 she had developed moderate
osteoporosis which had begun to somewhat
limit her mobility with all likeliness
of worsening she lived in an assisted
living center for elderly with memory
and mobility issues on a normal Sunday
her 16 year old granddaughter Olivia
visited her Sarah and her granddaughter
were very close and Olivia would often
visit to talk keep her company and ask
her for advice on this particular day
the two watched a movie together it was
a sad movie where someone died really
young from cancer when the movie was
over the two cried a little while they
talked about it at one point while
talking about life and aging Olivia
asked Sarah if she regretted anything
Sarah thought for a moment about how
honest she wanted to be with Olivia then
she answered and said that one of the
things she regretted is that she never
realized how good she had it until it
was too late until she was this frail
old woman alone in an assisted living
home with nothing to do she said that
she would give anything to be back any
age younger than 70 not even to do
anything different but to just do it
again to be 45 again and be passionate
and engaged in a job she thrived in to
still be a wife and a mother of little
children to still be front and center of
the orchestra of her life Sarah ended
with saying something along the lines of
don't overlook what you have while you
have it Olivia you don't realize how
good it is to be where you are until you
aren't and you don't realize how
young you are until you realize you were
just young for the last time ever don't
wait until you're my age it's no fun
after asking a few more questions the
two said goodbye with the hug and Olivia
went home leaving Sarah alone in her
room before turning the TV back on Sarah
thought about her own advice for a
moment she wasn't sure if she meant what
she said or if it was more of just what
she thought she was supposed to say if
she was in a movie or a story or
something she thought about how she was
essentially saying that life comes down
to being this old and everything before
it was good and everything after it is
basically the run off but then this made
her think about how even there she
wasn't listening to her own advice she
considered that in that moment she was
in fact existing in but another period
of her life that if she lived longer she
would almost certainly look back fondly
on that if in 10 years she was still
alive but completely bedridden or
beginning to lose her mind she would
look back at this time when she still
had a body and brain that worked a time
when she had essentially nothing to
worry about other than what activity she
wanted to do at the home a time when her
kids and grandkids visited her and she
still knew who they were this then made
Sara question how she looked at her
whole life during each moment she always
knew that she looked at the past through
rose-colored glasses she knew everyone
did and that this was just a cliche
written into the script of life but she
never really thought about what this
meant about the present that if
seemingly every version of the past
could be viewed through the positive
color of rose then that same shade of
Rose must exist in every moment in
period of life including this one and
that perhaps the problem is roses just
one shade of many colors that coat every
moment at the same time and when you mix
multiple primary and complementary
colors together you get a brownish or
grayish color and when you see a brown
or gray it's essentially impossible to
see the other shades of colors that help
make it she realized in this that even
in the mostly positive rose-colored
moments of life it didn't take much
green or yellow to make everything look
Brown and when reflecting back she
didn't see the other colors of anxiety
or stress not because they didn't exist
but because the stressful confusing and
overwhelming parts of her memories
weren't so stressful confusing
or overwhelming anymore now that she
knew how they were all resolved or no
longer relevant the complementary colors
dissolved away and left the primary
memory in and of itself
free from all the moods that painted
over the experience while she was
experiencing it but the Rose was always
there somewhere and in this moment Sarah
finally saw it while she was in it this
video was sponsored by Skillshare if you
aren't familiar Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
easy to follow professionally made
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial subjects like writing
film fine arts web development business
analytics and much more whether you want
to learn a new skill further develop an
existing one or inspire new ways of
thinking and approaching your life or
career Skillshare has a uniquely curated
in diverse collection of online classes
for just about anyone at any level
specifically if writing is at all of
interest one grade class available on
Skillshare is entitled autobiographical
fiction write a short story from
personal experience in which the class
teacher Adam Janos provides fantastic
insight on how to draw from real
personal experiences in memories while
harnessing the flexible nature of
fiction to better express and create
rich self reflective writing in general
no matter what the class skills platform
is tailored to the learning process with
various projects exercises and resources
associated with certain classes and a
communal component that allows for
helpful discussions in the sharing of
work with an annual subscription access
the skill shares constantly growing
library is less than ten dollars a month
and because skill share is sponsoring
this video the first 1,000 people to
click the link in the description will
receive a two month free trial of skill
shares Premium Membership of course
thanks so much for watching in general
and see you next video
[Music]